all right first thing I want to know
everybody keeps asking you about the
lyrics from bad boy and y'all still have
not gone on the internet and looked up
the lyrics we see cuz I am responsible
for the hook like I'm supposed to do the
hook he's supposed to do the verse
yeah figured it out I like the hook
everybody knows the hook no one knows
the letter words I heard you give it
like this like I know what does it mean
that all these years later 20 how many
years 25 after the original that you
still have the power to own the cinema
and take over Hollywood Boulevard what
does that mean young man let me tell you
it's like a 25 years is a really long
time usually when you're in in a movie
25 years after you was in the first one
they got you as the bartender or
something you doing something extra in
the background while the new guys you
know so I just I think it speaks to us
being ham scum Hanscom we'll just thank
you over there and it's because your
partner should have been somebody else
do you want to tell the world who it
should be well I don't want to stuff it
could have been in originally it could
have been Dana Carvey yeah it was it was
Dana Carvey and Jon Lovitz were the
original bad boys' that would have been
a little bit of a different movie that a
bit a different movie it would've been
bad boys I want to let show you guys
something holding pass me that what
would you tell these dudes this is back
in the day 25 years ago what do you say
to me
just living life just oh man I would
tell this dude that his lips should be a
little less red now your lips Oh red
it's like my lips are real red like yeah
that's not a good look and the suit
could fit like a little bit better like
it get easy just get a little closer to
my balls
it looks like he's like the fourth
member of guy all right 25 years ago at
that time 25 years ago you both had hit
TV shows I want to know if what you
remember about his showing what he
remembers about George can you name any
of the characters there Martin played
besides Martin
oh yes Sheneneh I was gonna say Otis
Sheneneh Otis
whoo Roscoe yeah that's right Roscoe and
Jerome yeah he helped you okay can you
give me the beginning of the Fresh
Prince theme where I spend most of my
day something like that damn close
[Laughter]
[Music]